LIKE YOUR LIFE DEPENDS ON IT.
LEE ZELDON NOT MINCING WORDS
WHEN IT COMES TO AMERICA'S
CRISIS.
ARRESTED FOR RAPING AND ROBBING
A 43-YEAR-OLD WOMAN WHILE SHE
WAS JOGGING.
THE REPUBLICAN HOPEFUL THAT
WANTS TO SEND KATHY HOGLE
PACKING IS LAYING OUT THE STAKES
FOR VOTERS.
>> UN DYER HERE HERE TALKING
ABOUT THE NEED TO TAKE BACK OUR
STREETS.
SHE SAYS SHE DOES NOT UNDERSTAND
WHY IT IS SO IMPORTANT WHEN I
WAS TALKING ABOUT THE NEED TO
LOCK UP CRIMINALS.
THE SAFETY ON KIDS EDUCATION AND
FREEDOM.
KATHY HOGLE IS NOT GETTING THE
JOB DONE AND I WILL.
>> VIOLENCE GETTING EVEN MORE
OUT OF CONTROL.
NINE PEOPLE SHOT OUT OF A BAR IN
PHILLY.
NEARLY 600 PEOPLE KILLED IN
CHICAGO SO FAR THIS YEAR.
ALL SHE SEEMS TO CARE ABOUT IS
GETTING FAMOUS ON TIKTOK.
WATCH ONE CONFRONT KATHY HOGLE.
>> I WILL INTERRUPT YOU THEN.
HERE IS THE PROBLEM.
WE DO NOT FEEL SAFE.
YOU MAY BE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
MAYOR ADAMS.
EVERYTHING IS ON LOCKDOWN
BECAUSE OF SHOPLIFTERS.
PEOPLE DO NOT FEEL SAFE IN THIS
TOWN.
YOU MAY HAVE DONE THESE THINGS
BUT RIGHT NOW WE ARE NOT FEELING
GOOD.
WE ARE WORRIED WE COULD BE SAN
FRANCISCO.
>> WE WILL NEVER BE SAN
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE WE ARE ALREADY MAKING
A DIFFERENCE.
>> SOMEONE FINALLY DOING THEIR
OWN ERRANDS.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
FOR HOW LONG?
WE GO OUT ONTO THE STREET AND BY
OUR TOOTHPASTE.
THEY SHOULD MAKE IT MANDATORY TO
WATCH THE FIVE.
IT WOULD HELP THEM.
THIS STUFF IS WHAT WE WILL TALK
ABOUT.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT CRIME, NOBODY
ELSE WAS.
I'M NOT SAYING I'M HAPPY WE HAVE
CRIME, I'M JUST SAYING IF YOU
LISTEN TO US, NOTHING POLITICAL
ABOUT IT.
WE WERE WORRIED ABOUT THE
COUNTRY SINCE THE RIOTS AND
LOOTING, WE KNEW THAT THERE
WOULD BE THIS MESS.
>> THIS IS PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT GOVERNORS RACE.
IF NEW YORK VOTES THAT PERSON
BACK IN AFTER THIS DISASTER, I
JUST DON'T KNOW.
THEN SHE BRAGGED ABOUT NO ONE
SPENDING MORE MONEY ON SAFETY
THAN HER.
YOU HAVE NO RESULTS.
PEOPLE ARE DYING.
>> YOU ARE WASTING OUR MONEY AND
YOU SUCK.
THERE ARE PEOPLE DYING BECAUSE
SHE NOT REPEAL A REALLY BASIC
WALL THAT IS ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
DIE.
>> HOW DO YOU SEE NEW YORK
TURNING OUT?
>> THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
STATE.
AN IMPORTANT STATE FOR THE
COUNTRY.
IT COULD HAPPEN ALL ACROSS THE
PROGRESSIVE PROSECUTORS, FOR
EXAMPLE.
WE HAVE SEEN IT IN PHILADELPHIA,
FOR EXAMPLE, AND LOS ANGELES AND
CERTAINLY ADDITIONAL RACES
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW ON THE LOCAL
PROSECUTOR LEVEL.
SO, HERE IS WHAT I THINK.
NEW YORK HAS NOT ELECTED A
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR IN 21 YEARS.
I BELIEVE NOW, THE TIME IS RIGHT
NOT JUST BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
GOVERNORS RACE BUT SEVERAL OF
THE HOUSE THAT ARE LIKELY TO GO
TO REPUBLICAN.
WRITING OFF ALL THE LONG ISLAND
SEATS AND MOST OF THE HUDSON
VALLEY SEATS AS WELL.
THAT INCLUDES SEAN PATRICK
MALONEY.
HE IS THE LEADER OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
TRYING TO GET THEM REELECTED TO
THE HOUSE.
LIKELY TO GET TAKEN OUT BY A
REPUBLICAN.
THOSE COULD PUSH ZELDON UP A
LITTLE BIT.
BUT IT IS VERY CLOSE, IT IS VERY
TIGHT AND THAT WILL BE A
NAILBITER ON ELECTION NIGHT.
>> DOES NEW YORK GO READ?
>> IF YOU LOOK AT HISTORY, IT
MAY VERY WELL GO FOR LEE ZELDON.
OBVIOUSLY, I SUPPORT HIM.
IF YOU RECALL WHEN GEORGE BECAME
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK WHICH WAS A
HUGE SHOCK, IT WAS AT THE HEIGHT
OF THE CRIME CRISIS.
WHEN JUDY RUDY GIULIANI IT WAS
AT THE HEIGHT OF THE CRIME
CRISIS.
ALL OF US ARE AFRAID TO COME OUT
OF OUR HOMES TO GO SHOPPING
BECAUSE IT MAY BE THE END OF US
IF WE GO TO A STORE OR GET ON
THE SUBWAY OR IF WE CATCH A CAB.
IT IS TOO DANGEROUS.
WHEN THE DEMOCRATS SHOWED THEIR
TOTAL MISALIGNMENT WITH THE
PEOPLE OF THIS STATE, YOU HAVE A
CLUELESS, HOPELESS GOVERNOR MORE
INTERESTED IN PUTTING MONEY INTO
A BUFFALO STADIUM WHERE HER
HUSBAND HAS THE CONCESSIONS WERE
INTERESTED IN SOME MICROCHIP
FACTORIES WHERE THE AVERAGE JOB
WOULD BE 600,000 OR SOMETHING
BECAUSE OF THE HIGH PAY LEVEL
PAYING PEOPLE.
SHE IS JUST CLUELESS ABOUT WHAT
IS GOING ON.
FOR HER TO SAY THAT IT IS ALL ON
LEE ZELDON'S MIND, SHE IS LIKE
MARIE ANTOINETTE.
WE DID ENOUGH FOR THEM.
SHE NEEDS TO GO.
>> WE MAKE 600 GRAND UPSTATE?
>> I SENSE WHAT YOU ARE SAYING
IS WHAT A LOT OF VOTERS ARE
SAYING.
DEMOCRATS, YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
I HAVE BEEN AS OUTSPOKEN ON THIS
ISSUE AND I AM A DEMOCRAT.
IF WE LOSE A GOVERNORS RACE IN
NEW YORK AND OTHERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND EVEN SOME MARROW
RACES ACROSS THE COUNTRY, IT
WILL BE BECAUSE OF THIS ISSUE.
I STILL GO OUT, I STILL GO TO
THE DRUGSTORE, I STILL GO TO
OTHER PLACES.
IF LEE ZELDON WERE PRO-CHOICE HE
WOULD BE 15 POINTS AHEAD.
THIS IS A TIGHT RACE. IS A JUMP.
DRIVING VOTERS OUT OF THE NEXT
FEW DAYS YOU WILL HAVE A SHOCKER
HERE IN NEW YORK.
>> I'M PREDICTING A LEE ZELDON
WHEN.
YOU CAN TAKE THAT TO THE BANK.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WHAT ARE YOUR INSIDERS
TELLING YOU AT T